I was definitely you know though wise
guy I was definitely you know full of
beans piss and vinegar all that I was
always making jokes you know complete
jackass and I thought was a short kid to
which i think you know some of that I I
feel like a lot of times the short kid a
kid who wait a while to grow
overcompensates with his jokes and I but
I separately I also knew I was going to
be a writer but I didn't know I was
going to be a comic writer there are two
separate things I always loved reading
and I always had a talent for writing I
know this is what i can do I was never
really excited by any other career
option you know I never thought oh gee
how cool would it be to be a lawyer or a
cowboy or a nap what do people think of
his career options I don't even know
yeah and I never got too excited by that
I I always want to be a writer and like
my heroes war writer three there's
heroes there's my my heroes were Walker
Percy and you know Hemingway and
Fitzgerald and these were people I
wanted to be this was a life I wanted to
emulate so but I never thought I'd be a
comic writer I thought it'd be a serious
writer I thought I was a poet I was
always writing as a teenager which it's
funny because I think there's nothing
that it annoys me now more than children
who write or precocity as a writer like
it you know I feel like leave it be you
know you'll get to it eventually but at
the time you know i just i knew i wanted
to write and i was constantly writing
for myself the to the wisenheimer side
and the literary side came together when
I went to Harvard and i joined the
Lampoon and which was is the comic
magazine there and i still i had no real
plan going in there just i was a funny
guy like and I like to write it seemed
like the right place to go and it was
also a time or you know when i was 16 i
thought you know I'm Baudelaire man i
was gonna I'm gonna write poetry you
know and then i'm 19 i'm like oh I need
to make a living I need a job and you
know several Lampoon graduates had
already gone into the world television
and movies and you know Doug Kenney
there's a hero a fantastic writer and so
I said oh well okay I can do this I knew
I could write an O could write funny I
said didn't I certainly new television I
was like this is a job for me and that's
when that happened
nothing elaborate you know I I was more
the insult comic you know and not witty
insult either a lot of lot of your
mother jokes a lot of and I did that's
still my stock-in-trade because because
they're really funny pranks no I
remember um you know what time i coated
my sister's room i mean everything with
talcum powder but that wasn't a prank
that was just kind of oh this is an
experiment like you know let's let's see
what her room would look like if talcum
powder was inside every single you know
crevice of the room and I gotten a lot
of trouble for that the pranks I do tend
to be a little more theoretical I
remember one time I was back in back at
college after graduation for one reason
or another and a friend of mine from
college was going to be there and the
sandwich shop down the street from where
we lived had closed I know and they
turned it into a sunglass hut which I
you know what could be worse you know it
was when the last place is a kid at
Harvard could afford to buy a sandwich
and now was just a place for tourists to
buy sunglasses
Elsie's exactly so so you you've been
there and it's gone now and I so I said
to my friend Scott he said you know I
use it he said let's grab lunch I was
like let's go to elsie's he said sure
because I thought maybe if we walk there
and he thought it was still there it
would still be there but it wasn't still
there so you